euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton hello and welcome to our
highlights edition let's kick start the
show today with a look at a few of the
reports coming up for you in the next
half an hour berlin by night
photographer robert garrn takes his
shots from an airplane dynamic duo
rocket and wink our ad executives who
are worth the show themselves and
affordable art that's the name of the
fair that makes art accessible to the
masses there are thousands of books on
the German capital of Berlin so if
you're visiting you can have your pick
of travel guides most of them will give
you restaurant recommendations and of
course an insight into the city's
history but perhaps the best way to get
a quick impression of Berlin is through
a photo book there is currently a new
one on the market by pilot and
photographer Robert gone he's combined
his two passions to produce fantastic
images of the city from a bird's-eye
view
the sky over Berlin that's full batt
cons workplace he's a specialist in
taking bird's-eye view photos by day or
by night the 50 year old knows the
German capital like the back of his hand
he's been a professional aerial
photographer for 20 years the students
on the wolf is I thought the best thing
about this profession is sitting in the
cockpit not above the clouds because
then you couldn't take any aerial photos
in the cockpit you can watch from above
how landscapes change and develop over
time at lunch to end off a nun Khan was
born in pasta just outside Berlin his
biggest challenge is nighttime
photography pictures as sharply focused
as these were unheard of just a few
years ago the latest digital technology
has made it possible earlier cameras
just weren't sensitive enough to light
and gun has a favorite Berlin building
to photograph day or night my pinky
before the last 15 years my favorite
motif has been Berlin's television tower
polished steel surface makes it possible
to take its picture from below at any
time of day and from the air you get
Berlin's skyline in the background into
it and it's fascinating no pictures like
another it's a new view every time you
just my tiptoes no implicit
gun is one of about 35 recognized aerial
photographers in Germany as a teenager
he dreamed of becoming a pilot when that
didn't work out he became a photographer
years later he found the way to combine
photography and flying you what about he
buying some photography was a roundabout
way of coming back to flying there are
strict criteria for becoming a pilot
back then I didn't qualify beat Ozzy and
later I found the way via photography at
some point after flying with lots of
pilots to take aerial photos I decided I
wanted to fly myself on my home 16 years
ago he got his pilot's license since
then he's flown and taken pictures at
the same time that way he gets exactly
the angle he wants it's huddle not if
you're sitting two meters away from the
pilot he can't imagine exactly what you
have or want in your viewfinder and then
at some point after I had my pilot's
license and enough flying experience I
realized I could combine the Kobe
needeth not mine Kron launched his own
photo agency in 1999 it's one of the few
in Germany that specializes in aerial
photos he has about 200,000 of them in
his archives he sells his pictures to
newspapers and magazines but also to
private clients Ron doesn't restrict
himself to Berlin he's taken aerial
photos of Dubai over the Persian Gulf
and in South Africa vitals and see
locals for the 2010 football world cup
in south africa we were the only photo
agency that offered aerial images of all
the stadiums i went all around south
africa and five days I munda little
dolphins at da photography we spent
eight to ten hours in the air every day
robot gone plans another photo book on
Berlin this time contrasting day and
night photos
he may know the German capital from the
air like no one else but even after 20
years there's always something new for
him to discover
and if you like to discover culinary
delights then you might want to check
out some of the restaurant guides
available in the Michelin Guide latest
addition they awarded 27 restaurants in
France with three stars we went to visit
one of those in the Champagne region
where the establishment as it turns out
has quite a decision at 39 I'll Nolan
mom is one of France's youngest three
star chefs the head of the kitchen at
lasya champa Noirs in the house he
stepped into the ranks of the elite just
a few weeks ago he's known for his
classic and purest cuisine his
specialities include spiny lobster and
breast pigeon with radishes Elmo
remembers reading the renowned gourmet
guide even as a child dig in chemo he
can be i grew up with cost Rana me
guides we read them a lot at home as a
child I even knew the names of many
three star chefs by heart the truth was
it worth it as a youngster he used to
watch his father Jean Pierre in the
kitchen Lamar knew then and there that
he wanted to be a chef hey papa I
annoying play long I felt very close to
my father he took me with him everywhere
the roastery shopping at the market the
vintner and fishing in pattaya on what
anyone that he thought if he taught me
the importance of good ingredients map
it was sabotage reporter after training
under several three star chefs la mole
started working in his family's
restaurant in 1996 in 2001 he regained
the Michelin star his father had lost
after his father's death he took over at
the restaurant and hotel his second star
came in 2005 his recipe for success
is simple let's also sold about I don't
even feel like it's worth every morning
I'm happy to get up and go to the
kitchen cooking is my passion I give
people my emotion and I get so much bang
famous jeweler golden penny Musa in
October 2013 the gormy yo guide named
our normal chef of the year and last
februari he received his third Michelin
star food critic ln Yogi's has followed
his career over the years personal teeny
video we wrote an article about him when
he still had two stars and even then it
was clear he'd probably have a third one
soon that was more interesting for our
readers because it's easier to get a
table in a 2-star restaurant everyone
wants to go to a three-star restaurant
and it's much pricier what makes our
known on more special is the quality of
his products the perfectly cooked dishes
and his outstanding classical technique
the quick quick ethic big names like
Alain Ducasse and poor boo Koos brought
French cuisine to the world for many
young chefs their role models back then
earning stars and other honors played an
important role and it still does
here in the renowned faculty culinary
school in Paris students dream of
getting a star one day every year some
200 young chefs come here from abroad to
get a taste of what French cooking is
all about that if you does your French
cuisine has an excellent reputation
that's in part because of its long
tradition and because the French care a
lot about food I put if all see it said
they spend more money on food than
people in other countries France is also
an agricultural country and has a large
variety of products look along with many
different kinds of wine and cheese dick
all of that plus the sophisticated
techniques have made french cuisine what
it is today it will give you a
certificate SEO classes are taught in
English a five month intensive course
costs nineteen thousand euros despite
the price tag there's no bitter taste in
the students mouths the attention to
detail the technique the flavors
obviously it's it's a very specific
French cuisine and so you can't just you
know open a book and
follow the instructions in the book
definitely will get a different result
than by coming to Paris and actually
working with the most professional
business after graduating the young
chefs can become apprentices at top
French restaurants including our new
landlords establishment now that he has
his third Michelin star less yet champa
Noirs is always booked but he wants to
keep the luncheon price the same at 68
euros as his way of saying thank you to
his longtime customers Ronnie all de
Vega is it it was quiz on our restaurant
has had good times and bad times people
have stood by us see the person they've
helped us and I'll never forget that
it's a loyalty it's very important to me
that's enough the young three-star chef
also serves a dish in honor of his
father lobster with potatoes his father
first came up with the recipe in 1978
and now on all al mall has given it a
new twist it's a special dish that he
hopes will be a mainstay on the menu
now if you're in the business of
marketing it's rare that the creators
share the spotlight with the product but
in the case of the German advertisers
rocket and wink businesses get the whole
package aside from putting together
successful ad campaigns this duo from
Hamburg have become known for remaining
unknown very few people have actually
seen their faces and this calling cart
could well have contributed to the
reason why they've just been named as
newcomers of the year It's Showtime with
Germany's craziest advertising duo
there's a pop star quality to helmet
wearing dr. Gerard Robertson or rocket
and Petronius Armand wink clad in jute
headwear amid much excitement they're
presenting their latest campaign at a
venue in Hamburg Rakatan wink don't talk
on camera but rely on Gary unclogged to
be there humorous mouthpiece but there's
no point in asking about their costumes
what costumes more serious answers are
occasionally forthcoming pop was a kiss
on music is a constant in the lives of
rocket and wink and that is a fact it's
beyond music is a source of inspiration
for rocket and wings on Rakatan pink
univer de musica on the whole they work
together but in their project rocket
versus wink they are opponents their
creative graphic dual has been going on
for weeks
rocket is red wing is blue they present
the results in their graphic magazine
whatever visitors to the show
experienced the final of the jewel as a
live battle the disciplines include
whipping cream playing chess and tearing
up telephone books in what amounts to an
entertaining art performance by two
advertising professionals
graphic design without rules sure
they're silly but I still like it the
pictures are strange and so is
everything about them the concept works
it's about communication right so it's
about making a brand so they make up
made a brand for themselves they've been
going for three or four years and
they're always doing cool new things
then the invention or influenza rocket
and wink have worked on around 90
projects since 2011 including a nike
campaign featuring german soccer star
measured ouzel last year they design
posters for a series of concerts for a
herbal after-dinner drink manufacturer
numerous German musicians turn to them
for their artwork rocket and wink our
designers illustrators product
developers and artists who regard
themselves as a think tank they have
reached the point where they can choose
their own clients until three years ago
they both worked in major advertising
agencies they only employed to permanent
members of staff in their little office
but that doesn't stop them winning
awards the rocket and wink style seems
to have an international appeal
Hinrich para vicini co-owns the Hamburg
advertising agency motor bore and his
head of design at the German art
directors club which recently gave
rocket and wink and award for its
campaign for a German newspaper my
sister companies will also give village
Marcus what makes this campaign so
unusual is that we can determine how a
major and rather traditional media
organization like oxes priya is willing
to go for a campaign that uses street
art and combines a sprayed look with a
rough and the broken that's very unusual
des is high transia I also give early
every two months rocket and wink changed
this billboard the drinks manufacturer
now on show is one of the agency's most
loyal clients many Fritz Kohler adverts
have a vintage look they are both
minimalistic and classic
this footage fish beside I would
describe them as the figureheads of a
movement we're experiencing a kind of
Renaissance of graphic artists in the
graphic design world and it's been a
major topic in Germany the two of them
pull it off perfectly Biden they love
the craft although one is more
traditional and the other is seen as
modern but they love making a craft out
of it out of using their hands
unfinished summer how apt then that they
should end their duel with a tug of war
given the dizzying prices that top works
of art fetch at auction these days it's
not much wonder that most of us feel
completely left out of the market one
that seems to respond hopelessly out of
control after all who can afford an
eight-figure sum for a Picasso or a van
Gogh but don't despair because Britain's
affordable art fair aims to bring a
breath democracy back into the game is
how
arts work after artwork finds a buyer
visitors to the affordable art fair in
London aren't exactly dainty about
getting their hands on the goods the
prices between 50 and 5,000 euros per
item are affordable for many people the
selection of ours on offer I think it's
the the most impressive thing I'm having
a little bit of difficulty making a
decision we bought two pieces already
and we're looking at a third yeah more
than a hundred galleries are exhibiting
works at the fair the atmosphere is
relaxed with music and wine making it
easier for you to part with your money
fifteen years ago we'll Ramsey founded
the affordable art there to open the art
market to a wider audience let's try and
break down this preconception that you
have to know that art to buy it this
barrier that stops people going into a
gallery we put the emphasis on the
visitors choosing rather than me the
gallery owner here art is defined by
what people like these three-dimensional
pictures and maps are the work of
Christiania Williams the Icelander
living in London also creates delicate
masks she and her three assistants
design materials for her own label as
well as for Paul Smith and Chanel
the Affordable Art Fair is very good
Christmas within a certain price range
so i think it's hugely important in
terms of like introducing people are
otherwise slightly you know scared of
buying the first piece of art it's a
very comfortable place to go and and by
which for me personally suits me very
well the works of pusst anna williams
combine art craft and design her sales
channels are pretty varied too she's not
only represented at the art fair by her
gallery she also has an online shop and
sells over the rise art platform I think
it is really good to have a site where
you're able to get a good selection
quite irritated something that
recommends different menus like there
you're able to borrow the artwork before
you decide to buy it the London start-up
rise art has more than 20,000 items to
choose from layers of filters help
buyers find what they want and for how
much collectors who want to can set up
their own profile founder Marcus Stuber
link wants to reach different target
groups
one type of customer that is basically
looking for great art to complement
their interior decoration or their house
you know as they as they invest more
into that living experience and then we
also have a bit more collectors because
we have art ranging from all the way
from fifty pounds up to like 50,000
pounds rise art also has pieces by
famous artists such as damien hirst for
example this limited edition of his spot
etching cine o logos for fifteen
thousand euros but most of the work on
sale goes for under a thousand euros
like Kevin Dutton's photographs of
plants which are available on the online
platform and at the fair
the online gallery it's an excellent
place to once you've made the decision
to buy an artist's work perhaps choose
which one you want but I think places
like this where you can see the art on
the wall for me I think that is still
essential whether online or offline
traditional definitions of art or
growing blurred fine art pop culture
designer furniture and sculpture hear
the opinions of art critics are no more
important than those of the visitors
wait weather in London New York Hong
Kong or Hamburg the Affordable Art Fair
has become a global phenomenon one that
shows that art lovers don't have to go
to museums to get what they want
as with so much of Switzerland the
general culture combines a deep sense of
tradition with a love for the outdoors
this is certainly true in the area
surrounding Lake through sound here
there are many different altitudes on
which you can explore a plethora of
different activities so we decided to
dive into the place quite literally
Kristoff karma is in his element among
the weird and wonderful creatures down
here as this I'm find a competent it's
just a totally different world of peace
in the car and you're on your own total
relaxation his favorite hunting ground
is Lake Lucerne sometimes the low
temperature 4 degrees Celsius on this
day means he has a maximum of 20 minutes
in the water the lake is surrounded by
the snow-covered peaks of the Swiss Alps
the small city of lucerne just on the
other side of the lake is the cultural
hub of central switzerland Christoph is
a big fan of the city because of its
variety of attractions and activities
it's my feeling i really like nature I
like sports I really like culture as
well and here in lucerne i can go diving
skiing and also go to the theatre
tourists are especially fond of the
historical center with its vibrant mix
of fascinating facades the 14th century
coppell work is one of the oldest
covered wooden bridges in Europe the
Town Hall is also popular as is the
shuttle gooch the towers over the old
city
but the most beautiful view is from the
water
first stop is the Rigi ban valley
station it's the first mountain rack
railway in Europe the train has been
climbing up the mountain since 1871
Martin Hart has been driving it for 25
years the old the Technic old technology
fire and water come together the driver
and the stoker have to work well
together it's a lot of fun what's all
assurance team door knocks weakish boss
visitors have a magnificent view at a
height of 1,800 meters locals called the
Rigi the queen of the mountains and then
they make their way back by sled it's
almost become a national sport here
eating is also a national sport
especially cheese locals here in SE
leesburg have been making it for decades
thomas ash fountains cheese business
goes back three generations every day
they transform 2500 liters of milk into
cheese k is it Easter Jesus Culture for
me in French they would say Laguna
Tawatha the taste of the place that's
what we're trying to preserve Alton
statements offers over to conceive
night owls can find adventure at the
ropes course in angry bear how about
lidl loves to come here with his friends
a cheese fondue awaits them as a zr2
persuaded of your norm it's very typical
for the region Hilton to meet up outside
at night to it's something from Kearney
and then to eat the cheese fondue after
going to the adventure park and what
better way to Debbie to spend an evening
and that brings us nicely to the end of
the show for today so all that's left
for me to do is say thank you for
joining us on behalf of all of the team
here in our berlin-based studios until
next time then take care of yourself and
could fly